-Yeah, it is good to be here,
but thank you for --
-You seem like
you're in a bad mood.
-I am in a bad mood.
Sorry. I am in a bad mood.
-Why?
-Because you bring
me out after Taylor Swift
and, like, all of
the excitement, the biggest --
one of the biggest stars,
and then it's deliberately
to sabotage
that I come out here.
-I'm not doing this
to sabotage you. I would --
-I come out here
in a corduroy shirt.
-I could hear you walking out
before you even came.
I'm actually so happy
that you're here
and I want to talk to you about
"The Last Best Hope,"
but I want to talk about,
just in general,
I saw somewhere that --
You're in such a bad mood.
Such a punk.
You are such a punk, man.
-You were holding it
sarcastically.
-I wasn't holding
it sarcastically.
-I'll hold it.
-I was holding in reverence.
-Oh, gosh. Alright.
I wanted to ask you a thing,
because I think this is
a compliment for you.
A lot of teachers --
-Oh, yeah.
-They're are asking you
for your last special
to be put online, because they
want to teach it to their --
They're teaching it
to their students.
-Actually,
they're not asking me.
They just use it.
Nobody's paying for it.
No money, no credit,
just use it at their classes.
But I am grateful for it.
I know it sounds like I'm not.
Because I consider myself --
I was always in that role with
Jimmy at "SNL."
I was really
a mentor and a teacher to you.
You were just a young,
wet-behind-the-ears boy,
and I told you -- I'm the reason
you have this show.
Remember what I said
when you were there?
-What is going --
-And I remember telling you --
Early on, I said,
"When you leave the show, do
a couple of unwatchable movies.
Then go into talk-show...
[ Laughter ]
What did I say?
-This is unbelievable.
-Hey, come on. Oh!
-Which one?
Give me that...
Which one was unwatchable?
-Oh...
[ Both laugh ]
-But this is -- Look at this.
You're doing material that is
going to go in
the educational system.
-I know. It is good.
-What kind of changes would you
make if you were a teacher?
What would you say
to these kids?
What do they have to learn?
-Well, here's the problem,
is our education system,
we teach what?
Study hard, bear down,
you'll be a success in life.
-Yeah.
-That's not our system.
We're a sales country.
We should be teaching kids
that the person
that studies hard, that goes to
work and just works,
and doesn't talk to anybody,
they go,
"That's the office psycho."
We're -- Teach personality.
Kids should be taught
first day of preschool --
Everyone has social anxiety.
Teach your kids to walk in
and memorize --
Like, just walk in first day of
preschool and be like,
"Is it me or is this
bus driver a little off?"
Something like that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, get people to...
-A little bit off.
-Teach them how
to work the crowd.
That's who does well
in our country,
the people that walk in
and be like,
"See? This kid knows what
I'm talking about."
The kid doesn't even know.
They're like this.
But you're like, "You get it.
You get it."
Just bond.
You're like, "The other kids --
I don't know if they get it.
You know, they're like zombies.
You get it, you know?
We need more kids like you in
this class, I'll be honest.
Not a lot of us left."
It's a personality country.
-Yeah, it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I just want...
Hold up.
Yo! Sit down!
-You're holding it
sarcastically.
You're holding it sarcastically.
Chris, Chris, how can I --
Chris, how can I help you?
-I just came to
see Taylor Swift, Jimmy.
-No, you missed Taylor Swift.
-Are these all military people?
-Yes, these are all military.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
25% got fake vaccines.
[ Laughter ]
-Chris, good to see you,
as always.
You missed Taylor.
I'll send you a link.
-Alright.
-I'll send you a link.
Chris Rock, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, that's great, Jimmy. Nice.
That was accidental, too?
Hey, let's bring out
Harry Styles
and Olivia Wilde next.
-Colin, when I talk about
"The Last Best Hope,"
you're going to go on
the road with this.
You're going to travel
the country.
-Oh, sure I am.
-Yeah.
But this is -- Can I ask you
about this, though?
"The Last Best Hope" --
who is the the last best hope?
-Well, it's a quote from Lincoln
about the country
being the last best hope.
But in this case,
it's "Colin Quinn,
The Last Best Hope."
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Colin Quinn,
The Last Best Hope"
is running now
through November 20th
here in New York,
then heading to
cities across the U.S.
For tickets,
go to colinquinn.com.